have you guys heard of this uh uh chick
Anna Bay b-e-y
I don't think so doesn't ring a bell for
me all right so I got this um I got this
video sent over and she's talking about
loser men so I thought I would review it
with you guys the title of the video is
Seven Signs he's a low value man and
then get out after that so let's see if
we uh can learn something here from Anna
um let me cue it up and get the sound up
on the screen
um
present
share
tab
here we go
all right and let's speed it up just so
this doesn't take the full 14 minutes a
little bit
now I'm gonna have to pause this every
few uh seconds to sort of uh chime in on
it because otherwise YouTube doesn't
like that you can you can actually play
other people's videos and
um do it uh on your Channel with any
issue as long as you make commentary on
it so you're so you're providing
feedback so we'll pause and we'll
feedback on points that she's making
Here My Dear I'll get ladies now there
might be seven signs that you are dating
a loser okay when I say loser I don't
necessarily mean a loser to tell you the
truth low quality where do you think
she's from She's Eastern European for
sure right easily usually Matt was too
long to write in the title so let's keep
it simple by just calling him a loser
today but in reality I'm really
referring to any form of man that might
not be worthy of your time your effort
and your love whatsoever sadly in our
society a lot of women are being
desperate a lot of women are wasting too
much time on the wrong type of man and
in this video we are stopping with a
behavior as of right now before we start
with Point number one you need to be
aware that of course there might be some
things that are going to sound like the
partner you are with right now I'm not
telling you to leave him but I'm telling
you that maybe you should start thinking
about setting boundaries and your own
self-worth now let's dive into it sign
number one you're dating a loser if he
expects you to go 50 50 in relationship
with him or if you want so to kind of
frame her Channel a little bit I mean
she goes on a lot about
finding high value men what a loser
looks like how to be a classy woman sort
of thing
what do you guys think of this first
sign you know he expects you to go 50 50
on the relationship
yeah I think that's valid I mean it's it
depends what we talk about when it comes
to 50 50 right everybody has this idea
50 50 but I'm assuming 50 50 meaning
it's 50 50 percent like decision making
or 50 50 Financial contributions uh and
yeah it women want a leader and women
want to fall into a guy's frame and if
she feels that she's your equal or you
make her your equal she'll never look up
to you and she'll never be led by you so
I I have no problem with that what about
you uh 50 because you're an LTR so what
do you think about 50 50 in the
relationship yeah
um well when I first engaged in the LTR
I was told that what was really a turn
on and thanks to you in the community
was I took the lead on everything and I
did everything and I made the decisions
and I was told yeah so again what she's
experiencing is better men conditioned
by blue pill and come in and go let's go
let's let's I'm asking for your input on
this honey and what do you think you
know and what do you think will dry a
woman up like the Sahara Desert
yeah let's just finish playing it let
her sort of explain the point but
first of all we are not 100 equals and
we can never become equals simply
because biologically we are not built
equally okay men have a certain
Advantage biologically speaking than
women wealth women because you know we
are the caretakers we're the ones who
carry the child Etc we might never have
the same equal opportunity to make the
same career to make the same amount of
money Etc plus as you know on the job
market women tend to earn less than that
so uh
so now she's talking about some nonsense
now on the job market women tend to earn
less than men that's probably where
she'll get into the hang on you know on
average it's just
changing but not only
you didn't specify that it's because
women choose jobs that pay less and work
lower hours and there's lower bonuses
there's lower lower risk stuff like that
but she's just sort of framing it you
know to the point that men make more
than women so it shouldn't be 50 50. men
should lead and pay because when we get
pregnant and they don't earn as much
money but what I'm wondering is
it is she going to give the guy the
authority over the relationship because
if you have the responsibility to pay
for everything and to lead do you have
authority right that's where I have
problems with you know with stuff like
this is they want you to have
responsibility to pay to set up the
dates to take you out on dates you know
to buy and take care of the nice cars
and all that sort of stuff but this
should give the guy Authority let's find
out different types of expenses demand
simply because they are women we
actually have to spend more to keep
ourselves attractive and of course we
are attractive because men want us to be
attractive women spend more on clothes
than men women spend more on Senator
products than men women spend more on
beauty prices
et cetera okay so she's admitting that
women are Beauty objects
sorry so if he wants to go through
physician relationship that just simply
shows that he doesn't want to step into
this masculine role plus he is not a
provider and he might not even be
generous so I don't know if those are
the qualities that you want to work with
in this relationship I'm not forcing
this upon you if you are applying with
this then that's absolutely okay no hard
feelings for my end but I'm just here to
tell you that it's okay as a woman to
expect
does she look like the kind of chick
that would give you Authority
I was going to mention that like with
the because I know these types of living
in California the fake lips she's got
work done on her face and also I'm very
very uh into what words people choose to
use this language so the word generous
that doesn't mean what it used to mean
it doesn't mean you're nice that you're
that you're caring that you're giving
generous usually means like you you pay
for her time or company especially guys
around seeking Arrangement you know what
that word generous means so that kind of
tips me off to the type of girl she is
which I could tell anyways because again
I have the experience of dating you know
different types of girls she's a six
with a good hairdresser well yeah you
know she's got the makeup on she's got
the hair dye you know whatever sure I I
personally wouldn't wouldn't I don't
like those kind of fakie types anyways
she she may not know what she's actually
saying but what she's saying here in the
first minute our first two minutes is
she was an alpha male who takes the lead
yeah
that's it yeah yeah the man has to pull
Financial load a bit more than the woman
in a relationship sign number two that
you are dating loser and that is if he
makes you feel weird or crazy or a
psychopath or clingy if you want
commitment from
if you want com so she's obviously post
wall like she's got to be in her 30s
right
if if he makes you feel inappropriate if
you want a commitment there's nothing
wrong with that you know if you want he
said those words she said those words
are too much conviction too I'm sure
it's you know to be an entrepreneur it's
like oh I'm weird I'm weird I'm like
yeah like crazy psycho clingy weird like
these I mean they're kind of started
starting to fade from the edit but yeah
those are clearly words that she wanted
to uh hover on
foreign
are we not or let's say you want to have
an engagement or let's see what marriage
or you want kids Etc there are so many
men out there who paint the picture as
if the woman is a the psycho who wants
these things but something is wrong with
her like like stop pushing me type of
thing this is the thing I'm not saying
it should only be the way us women want
it do you think she's heard that
conversation a few times
I'm sure that's why she's saying that
yeah
it doesn't mean that that's fair okay
but there has to be a way where we meet
halfway this is a disadvantage of being
a woman we have a body clock to think of
we can't just you know spend 10 years
waiting for him to finish clubbing and
the media then he will decide if he
wants to marry or not but again see this
is a problem that I have with this it's
like you know your post wall you're kind
of in your mid-30s and you're getting
mad at guys for not wanting to commit to
you or start a family with you but
like you're you're kind of at the end of
your reproductive cycle anyway right
like maybe like what are you gonna do
you're gonna have one or two and you
might have a high-risk pregnancy tied
into that so it sounds like it's not
exactly that the guy doesn't want to
commit it's that oh I don't make me feel
crazy well that what that leads me to
believe is that he doesn't want anything
guys well guys are push put guys are
passing the buck on to the chick saying
oh you're crazy you're psycho as opposed
to saying yeah like I'm just not into it
because guys these guys are not owning
up to it they might not want it but
they're not being honest about why they
don't want it and they're not you know
stepping up and owning that [ __ ] yeah
that's my question these types of girls
like why why is it that she hasn't found
because she was probably really
attractive in her 20s why hasn't she
found a guy that she's been able to lock
down why is she post walled why is she
even having these conversations because
again guys like us if you met a girl
that's like 18 to 23 like Prime you know
low body count checks all the boxes
those girls get snatched up off the
market immediately so this leads me to
believe she was riding the carousel all
through her 20s and the way she talks
she's definitely Alpha widowed because
if she was dating decent guys she
wouldn't have these conversations and
she wouldn't be here doing videos she'd
be in a happy healthy marriage that's a
perfect perfect analysis Jaron I was
going to say the same thing the passion
and the intensity and the words she used
there's a few high value alpha males in
her past that she failed to lock down
and she's just over it she's been burned
no little disclaimer there are of course
valid and reasonable situations when
sometimes you do need to give a person a
little bit of time a little bit of space
but this is where I'm talking about you
need halfways don't let it just be how
he wants it don't let it only be how you
want it it has to be an equal
opportunity that's what we want wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
it has to be equal opportunity wasn't
her first point you know don't go 50 50
men and women aren't equal
isn't that amazing he's just talking
about money isn't that amazing how it
how it goes from when it comes to money
he needs to pay for everything but when
it comes to the relationship he needs to
consider My Views and values it's like
that previous guy like it's got to be
women that are easier trash but Notch
count doesn't matter like which one is
it yeah
fine number three but you're dating a
loser if he is flaky because you
vanishes or is completely unreliable
um I'm just going to say this if he's
flaky ghost who vanishes or completely
unreliable it's because you're not his
priority he's got other things that are
more interesting or maybe another chick
that's a higher priority than you oh how
did we all met this type ladies
hang on let's see if we can pause on her
face here where it zooms in because it's
like I was gonna say she has crazy she
has crazy eyes she's completely
unreliable yeah look
[Laughter]
somebody you've all met that type his
name is Chad
somebody needs to meme this somebody
needs to meme this guys get on it 50.
yeah yeah I'll get on it I'll get on it
it'll be like why won't you marry me
that's that [ __ ] some guy saw that face
and and the face was was immediately
followed by the phrase
because we were all thinking that that
is how have we all met this type ladies
now this is such a classic scenario
especially you know how if we also met
so many women who are like oh I love him
so much she basically accepts the type
of behavior or what she puts up with it
because well I don't really have
anything better going on for myself uh
well I kind of like this guy you know
you see what I mean there is no excuse
for do you guys like filled lips
no me neither no no not really I like
full lips that are natural but not
filled like yeah not like that it just
it just looks weird when she makes those
faces
I need to tell you one thing that rule
number one is dating is that if he
doesn't keep his promises he's
unreliable if he knows you then one time
okay things happen second time bye
ladies you don't deserve to be with
somebody who can I agree with that I
mean look you know if you're if you're
post-wall and you're looking for you
know marriage or kids or family or
something like that or like you've got
you've got a uh a timeline like she
clearly does then fine but you know at
the end of the day if the guy does that
it's because you're not that interesting
to him over a long-term basis he just
didn't see you as a priority so ghosting
is the most clear form of communication
I mean like women do it to guys way more
than guys do it to women so it's like
you know I don't know it's just a double
standard that it exists whatever cancels
on you last minute for basically no
reason or repeatedly doing this as part
of his behavior I mean are so many
examples but I think we all have been
through with flaky men and men who
simply gives us all these promises and
then nothing ever happens all these
promises came because actually he had an
agenda he wanted to how many times do
you think she got dumped
there was at least four serious
relationships or an engagement I think
there was an engagement broken off here
probably
so that you would give him
him
but this subject really fires me up yeah
it fires her up because it happened a
few times that's why which one thing I
wanted to note like and I I tell this to
guys all the time like don't lead your
girls on because this is the type of
product you're going to produce and some
other guy is going to have to fill the
wrath of that if you don't want to marry
her if you don't want to have kids be
clear in your communication from the
get-go guys guys gonna be all the time
like oh you're using these girls like
these girls know exactly what they're
getting like from from the description
on my Tinder profile if you guys watch
my Channel or you're in the private
groups they know exactly what they're
getting into there's no leading on here
so uh so I could see like she could be
she probably has been burned or scored
by guys in the past but guys if you're
in that situation especially if the
girls like nearing 30 like cut bait let
her know like hey I don't see this going
anywhere like we want different things
we're not compatible we're different
chapters of our lives whatever and let
her go because this is what you're going
to create if you're doing that kind of
stuff yeah there's like an army of of
mid-30s women that are out there like
this that are that are really burnt
pretty bad because
they they kept pushing a guy that didn't
want to be pushed and maybe he maybe
didn't have the balls to put his foot
down and say look you know I like you
like having fun with you uh FWB is is
fine but I'm not going to marry you you
know just just be honest like Jared said
firecracker let's just say exactly how
it is if a man isn't consistent I really
don't believe he's not into you like
okay that's a cliche saying but it
really is that simple a man who is into
you he is going to call you he is going
to make an effort he is going to Clyde
mountains and walk on seas in order to
see you even if it's a bit difficult
right now yes it's hard to meet high
quality man I get it because men are so
spoiled today it's truly a challenge but
what's worse is settling for Less I mean
I'd rather be single than be with
somebody who is really not up to the
level that I think I deserve to be
treated
and that's why you're single today
I think I deserve yeah I I want this see
this is your Modern Woman you know this
is the uh I mean this chick's Eastern
European obviously so she's not the
Avatar that Kevin Samuels you know would
talk to but this is the modern woman
that that Salmons would often describe
right like I want this I want that I
demand this I demand that by this sort
of thing and it's like I've said before
like these boss girls are just
disagreeable uncomfortable women to be
around over a long-term basis so why
would you want to listen to all this
screaming and shouting challenge we
don't know where to meet men and where
to meet the Elites in general so you
know that I do have a cheat sheet with
over 210 places of ideas and suggestions
for you where you can actually go to
meet men to meet the Elliot and should
we should we dance cheat sheet and
covered it some other time yes yes
in one brush in one breath women are
strong and independent but in the other
breath here's how to find the
millionaire guy and here's how to land a
good guy yeah which is it yeah yeah
simply making new connections this is a
free gift from me to you just simply go
to familiarplaces.com and download this
free cheat sheet today now sign number
four that you are dating a loser and
okay before I say what it is I'm about
to say I know that some of you ladies
are going to have a partner like this so
my disclaimer is that this is just a
cliche example if he does some of these
things doesn't mean that he's a complete
loser of course not but I'm just giving
this to you as a guidance and I think
you can also see that this is a bit of a
metaphor for the type of persona
describe so here we go sign number four
you're dating a loser if he leftstep has
no other interest then watch football
drink beer play video games and watch
porn yeah so she's describing a low
value guys so I agree yeah it's like
there's a generalization this is
stereotyping Etc it's just a metaphor in
this case this could be translated in
all kinds of different shapes lines and
forms in reality all I'm saying is about
a man who lacks depth because you know
there's a stereotype that women or
oftentimes women can be AirHeads
especially blonde women so you know they
say that a woman can easily be an
airhead a down the bimbo a blondie you
know all those horrible stereotypes but
come on have you never heard about the
fact that a man can equally be so and
the fact that actually in this world
there are so many of them oh yes I don't
have many of them they even exist in
High Society believe it or not first of
all I think we can all say that it's not
very attractive I don't really know what
you're going to have a comment with each
other Vic can you just meet yourself I
think there's some feedback coming
through bro
even though that's this you're here on
this channel you're probably very
elegant and cultivated and have a brain
going for yourself that you don't really
want to be with somebody who is less
intelligent than you just think about
what are you going to be talking to this
man about for the rest of your life
let's say you become married I know I
think life is for sure it's a waste of
the wrong person make sure you find
somebody you have things in common with
sign number five that you are dating a
loser and that is if he lacks any form
of basic gentleman skills and gentleman
skills come on I think this is very
Universal so
I'm just going to take a stab at this
right now because I've seen this movie
before and I Know How It Ends but it's
probably going to go to shaming he
doesn't pay for whatever he doesn't
commit to okay let's just find out what
she says with the gentleman skills we
don't even really have to pay attention
cultures I think that holding out the
door for a woman rather than throwing it
in her face okay I agree with that yes
basic manners all men kind of know about
right well let's say as an example
you're walking next to the man and it's
a little bit chilly you're wearing a
short sleeve top or something like that
and it's a little bit cold and he
doesn't offer to give his jacket to you
but one of the things no that's
interesting because I've I've gone out
and you know it's been cold and be like
you know you should grab a jacket and
then she does it and then she's cold and
it's like okay so do I have to be cold
now give her my jacket because she's too
stupid to put a jacket on because she
didn't listen
I don't know
see a lot and this I think you also know
isn't the man is so nonchalant doesn't
really care about his woman he walks in
front of her he doesn't even wait for
her doesn't even look back to see if
she's still behind yeah that's a
douchebag move for sure you know so rude
and not gentleman whatsoever you know
small things like that that really shows
if a man is a gentleman and you know I
recently spoke about a sex etiquette
when a man is selfish in bed that's no
gentleman that's not nice especially
considering how physically we are
structured where again the woman has a
more tougher card to play with than the
man anyways that were just a few
examples of uncultured this is where the
uh black pill mgtow guys will be like
yeah but she's destroyed her
destroyed herself with all her toys and
buzzed herself to that sort of thing
it depends on the check too I've noticed
with a lot of chicks the more selfish
you are the more she gets off on it and
then she gets off by the fact that
you're getting off in fact guys again
once you have more experience you'll
start to notice these things that her
pleasure is derived from seeing you get
pleasure from her it's a positive
feedback loop I yeah this trick is
insufferable though like she's uh she's
an exhausting broad for sure behavior
from
Down Below in the comment section I will
be reading the model sign at number six
you're dating a loser if he starts
manipulating you once you understand
that you know what
manipulating is this going to go to her
doing things that he wants her to do
like you know the authority part like
she's okay with him paying for
everything but is this going to go to
like him wanting to place boundaries on
her time so let's see what she says
that's what manipulation means I need to
reclaim some unfairnesses it has been
going on so he starts saying that you're
materialistic you're the b word you're a
gold digger or who knows maybe he says
be quiet woman who do you think you are
sit down I'll go to the kitchen go back
to your place I mean truly you might I
don't know I've told my chick to make a
sandwich for me before what's wrong with
him he just listed everything I say to
my I took every day
it's funny that these are the things she
hears because that tells you the type of
girl she is again like I I can't
remember the last time I told the girl
you're a gold digger because I screamed
gold diggers out of that equation they
don't even come in the door yeah Vic
what do you think man you've been
sitting there quietly
oh you're muted
um there you go
dude you sound like Mickey Mouse what
happened
no your audio's messed up
you have a helium tank behind me did you
inhale
let them come back in maybe there's
something wrong with his audio
number seven is but I have a real hunch
that I want to release after I see the
seventh one but I want to I want to
chime in on something but yeah let's go
ahead okay hold on hold on kitchen go
back to your place I mean truly you
might think but I'm joking right now but
there are many men like that I think it
is a warning sign if a man is reacting
aggressively once you start setting Fair
boundaries and when I say fair
boundaries because I know that it's hard
to understand in the beginning am I
doing the right thing am I being too
selfish now myself is this fair or not
but you really need to trust the
situation and your voice can take some
advice from your surroundings as well
but if you are setting Fair boundaries
where you are not being suicide I miss
you guys a question
um she's you know she used the b word
you know calling her a [ __ ]
um
I think generally speaking guys don't
throw that word around Loosely it's like
if you use it it's probably because
she's being a [ __ ]
that'll be the first and last time I use
it yeah I don't use any like the s word
W word you know like [ __ ] hoes
I don't use any of those words with with
my girls yeah how's my voicemail there
you go there you go all right before you
sound like everyone sounded better I
know that happens when I first connector
sometimes but I don't know so like your
thoughts on this Anna bachuk uh I don't
know I mean she's saying some stuff that
that makes sense but like when you when
you were saying like the jacket thing
it's like you told her before you head
out the door to put on a jacket and she
does it but it's like if you're out and
it suddenly turns cold then yeah I would
I would offer her my jacket and some of
the stuff she says makes sense you know
but um
I she's like citing like really extreme
examples I mean for some of the stuff
she's saying she'd have to be with a
real [ __ ] [ __ ] in my opinion I
don't know or she has to elicit that
behavior with her oh yeah
yeah you're you know you're out there in
the dating market right now Vic is this
kind of woman that you would date
um
I don't know it's not the type of woman
I've been dating uh to me this is to me
this is kind of like a uh she's a
seeking chick that uh is like looking
for sugar daddy that that's kind of like
the vibe that I get from her yeah
yeah she's a bit too old for you brother
selfish now you it's not just about what
you want it's about meeting halfway
that's what boundaries is all about and
as a man reacts very harshly very
crazilia I think you need to be a little
bit cautious so again you know like the
double standard like meeting halfway but
her first complaint and her first point
was he should pay for everything
right like that's fine you know I'll pay
for everything I'll take care of the
dates you know you go on vacations but I
need authority over the relationship
right if you want me to have
responsibility financially then then I
need that Authority that goes along with
responsibility but it's like whenever
it's convenient for women like this
today you know the Modern Woman it's it
it goes to well you pay for everything
but I want 50 50 here no it doesn't work
that way right it's it's got to be
consistent across the board so I don't
think she's given good advice to women
here so what you're dealing with because
potentially this could be a man that you
should be stepping away from there are
men who are just narcissistic selfish or
too defensive or lack ability to do any
form of change within themselves now I
don't know if that's where to build a
future with so that potentially the
situation where you have to choose
yourself and choose your own needs first
because believe me there are men who are
willing to meet you halfway who are fine
with certain boundaries in a
relationship I have a feeling she's been
choosing herself for about 35 years
we're not expecting you to be a doormat
or to do everything for him or to be all
about the way he wants things to be be
careful ladies sign number seven and the
last sign that you are dating a loser
and that is if you are in serious
committed relationship with somebody who
is still partying all night long every
weekend and cannot be without his
collabing with the boys pretty much
every weekend now okay one thing is if
let's say you are 19 years old both of
you or you are also in that type of
Lifestyle was that the one that you were
going to pick muff
no it's it's more overarching on the
entire thing so we can I'll say it once
we finish up okay I meet a lot of girls
like that what's that I made a lot of
like party girls party girls much more
than guys like well into their 30s and
40s and sometimes 50s like girls
especially where I live because you know
it's a party whatever culture but the
girls all the time oh why aren't you
going out tonight like it's Tuesday
she's almost giving away there what
happened to her with the Chad who either
dumped her at her engagement she had a
high value guy who was still going out
and had options and it really ticked her
off I would yeah I would co-sign that
100 50. I think that's that's probably
what went on here I don't know in their
30s and up maybe even late 20s as well I
don't know it's hard to put labels but I
wear a maneuvering here
departing every weekend every Friday
every Saturday all night long and
especially without you okay if you do
that together as a couple because you
love to have fun you love to drink you
love stands whatever but if he has such
a strong need to be Mr party boy and I
don't really know what you're doing with
him it's just a bit strange that if
somebody is in a relationship and still
needs to be doing all that she she
strikes me as the kind of woman that's
like burnt angry
counts her eggs drying up every single
month on a calendar and is frustrated
that a guy hasn't committed to her and
projecting this out it's like
this is like again this is this is Kevin
Samuels Avatar of a modern Woman except
for she's white in Eastern European
like like a woman who's dated the Bad
Boys she was attracted to Bad Boys she
Gates the bad boys and now she's
bitching about [ __ ] bad boys yeah
yeah but there's no reason she shouldn't
there's no reason she should she should
have an issue having locked a guy down
in her past there's a reason that she
didn't and it's likely because of her
but Rich you say it all the time women
never take a mirror and look back at
themselves like okay why why did I not
get married in my early 20s well because
she didn't want to she was with her
girlfriends she was probably a party
girl she was probably going after the
bad boys the alphas the Chads and now
she's she's paying the piper she's
paying the consequences of not having
secured a guy before her 30s all right
let's finish this up here different
situations are different so everything
that I've said in this video of course
it might not be 100 applicable in your
situation even though some of these
signs um resembles your partner but
think about are you really being treated
the way you deserves to be treated are
you setting Fair boundaries are both of
you meeting each other halfway because
that's what it really is all about it's
not just what he wants it's also what
you want don't forget that my delegate
ladies in the next video how to make
impacts with your attention you're going
to find out exactly how to be the one
that the man runs how to make him beg
for your attention I bet it's got
something to do with ghosting him and
ignoring him and putting some distance
between you and him let's just see what
the comments say here what's our top
comment anyway
another type of loser is one that
insults yours and considerate she
covered that oh these are all checks
watching her Channel Sarah says my mom
mom always said what you see is what you
get you want a partner you can grow and
evolve with not a project that you have
to pull put all your energy into
yeah there's one from a dude right there
yeah Nick as as a man the biggest
problem I see with the women is poor
character judgment and man is a man I
can see bad traits and other men
immediately cowardice and security
narcissism manipulative young men now
this guy's like
one of these dudes it's something for
like why is he watching a a channel
that's built trying to get them set up
with high value guys right
anyway I find that hilarious so moth
like what did you think the uh yeah I
think that it just goes to show that the
vast majority of men are invisible to
women it's so funny that she's talking
about you know men being losers but
everything in this video is her attempt
with the exception of the porn and the
drinking and the football lazy boy thing
this is her attempt at building a better
beta so she's only talking about the
things that she wants in Alpha Chad rich
guy who's in great shape who gets her
wet to do
but she doesn't understand that these
are not the traits so so your everyday
rent the everyday Joe that's watching
this video is thinking all I got to do
is pay for stuff all I got to do is
listen to her not go out and have any
fun I've got to not manipulate her and
I've got to do all these beta male
little traits with the exception of the
porn thing like I said they gotta do all
these and now I'm gonna be able to get
all these beautiful women
and this is exactly the kind of [ __ ]
and lies and poison that young men are
being exposed to today and this is
exactly how we developed this blue pill
thinking and this is exactly how we wind
up with people like person or who just
think okay cool like I'm just gonna do
these seven things and I'm gonna get the
girl in my dreams but there was nothing
in here about how do you know if you're
dating a loser he's a fat [ __ ] he can't
bench press his body weight he doesn't
have any sort of muscle mass whatsoever
like he doesn't do any sort of Combat
Sports
um you know it doesn't take care of
himself doesn't dress well nothing like
that like these the the things that
actually attract women at a surface
level or off rip uh all all about how
can the guy I'm already attracted to and
want to be with provide me with beta
comfort and not Alpha attractiveness hey
guys I really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out